it's great to welcome to the program
today Martin Guri who is a former CIA
analyst and author of the revolt of the
public first published in 2014 and
updated in 2018 great to have you on
Martin I appreciate your time happy to
be here so when you look back at some of
the revolts of the last decade so you
know Occupy Wall Street the Hong Kong
protests Arab Spring we're seeing unrest
in Paris right now do you see any sort
of common thread between them well what
we have is essentially a eruption from
below that's made possible by the fact
that I think our our systems of
governments which are whether they're
democratic or dictatorial based on and
the industrial model this is when when
our government took its form can't
withstand the amount of information that
the digital world has thrown at it so
they have very much in common they have
they seem to be the model is almost like
an Internet chat room or there's no
leaders there are no spokespersons there
are no programs certainly no ideologies
but they're very anti ideology so as you
can tell I am NOT a young person when I
was young if you were good could have a
radical movement you needed essentially
a mini hierarchy that you wanted to
overthrow the government with today that
is not at all what you see in any of
those revolts that's interesting and so
in a sense it's the technology of the
last 10 years that have enabled I guess
we would call it a flatter
infrastructure rather than a
hierarchical one to take hold yeah I
think it's a collision between
information enabled by technology and
systems and it's not just government I
think you could say the same about every
major institution that that modern
society is sustained by systems that
require
roll over the information and their own
domains and because of this enormous
tsunami of information generated by the
digital universe that semi monopoly of
information has been lost and the second
that happened these institutions
including government including politics
the political party you say have lapsed
into what I've called that crisis of
authority it seems that this is a double
edged sword though in the sense that on
the one hand the Internet has greatly
democratized reporting information
availability diversity of sources so on
and so forth and at the same time this
has been a catalyst for the crisis of
fake news and disinformation the
inability to distinguish fact fiction
opinion and reporting so on and so forth
how what's your sense of the balance of
those two forces well I mean I think
there is no balance I think we are in a
totally fractured environment when you
have a crisis of authority you are bound
to get a crisis of uncertainty okay so
you people live in what I call the
public it I don't mean by that the
people I don't mean by that the masses
the public is essentially the old mass
audience which in my day when I was
younger it was like an enormous mirror
that you saw yourself reflected in well
that mirror has shattered has fallen it
has shattered and the public lives in
the broken pieces and each piece seems
to have its own way of collecting and
analyzing information that can be very
different from all the others the pieces
are mutually hostile
and barely sometimes connect about what
is a fact and what isn't one of the
things that I find really interesting
that you write about is that it is much
easier for large groups of the public to
unify around something that they are
against something that they reject than
it is around sort of positive things
that that they want to do and this you
know when you when you look at for
example local news and you see how
sensationalism and stories of crime and
negativity do far better than other
types of stories
there seems to be something inherent
there to the way that people are
motivated to say to their neighbor hey
did you see this bad thing that's going
on that is much more there's something
about that that Spurs action much more
than hey let's get together and do this
positive thing do you agree with that
assessment and what what are the
implications of that when it comes to
activism well when you look at that
fractured environment I just described
each one of those fragments has its own
you know you could be the Tea Party you
could be a feminist you could be Bernie
bro there is very very different ways of
parsing information and data and if you
want to mobilize that unify this very
fractured environment the only way to do
so is by being against and there is this
tremendous swelling of anger against the
established order so what would you have
in many of these revolts and you can
start with Tahrir Square in Egypt and
all the way to Hong Kong you have people
from every kind of political opinion but
they are unified against they want to
overthrow the system as they exist the
danger as you point out is if you're
against and you are as these people tend
to be not interested in alternatives
then you can run into what I call
nihilism which is basically the belief
that the destruction of the system for
its own sake is a form of progress and I
mean I leave you to consider that I
don't think it is well that seems to be
one of the big divisions that exists on
the Left right now which is the work
with the system to improve it mentality
compared to the burn it all down to
eventually rebuild something better
ideology I don't have any moral
imperative one way or the other I think
if you look at history the incremental
ISM seems to have achieved more as I
understand it but I'm not ideologically
or emotionally attached to one movement
or the other but that that seems to be a
very prominent discussion happening
right now on the left
well you burn it all down then what
like the the the difference between
today and say 1917 you were a Bolshevik
or even 1959 you were a Castro issed
you know is you have a an organization a
program and a set of ideologies and you
want power to put those in place you
tear it all down today what do you get
you you basically have people who are
activists in condemning the government
and then turning around and asking the
same government that they are condemning
well we need you to do this and that and
the other verses I want to take over the
era of revolution in my in my humble
opinion as an analyst pretty much died
in 1991 so you're not going to do the
Bolsheviks or Havana at Cubans 59 over
again
so what the public can't yet do that
maybe it should be working towards is
articulate positive demands what is it
that it can actually share together when
it rises up duck it doesn't hong kong
like it doesn't until a for example well
the one that now seems to be potentially
on the cusp is the movement in the
united states for some kind of
single-payer healthcare system or
medicare for all which is as it sees
itself anyway it sees itself as a
positive movement it wants to do
something good it is a movement that
believes that can improve things for
people if the system is changed but at
the same time it's been born in
opposition to the status quo
so do you would you consider that
movement a movement for something or is
it still a movement against i mean i i
find that kind of a circular thing
you're saying that the people in charge
are corrupt that's usually the charge
has made the they are incompetent they
are distant and self-serving okay and
yet you're saying well but i but i have
this massive government program that I
want to hand to them that that just
doesn't work I mean my feeling is you're
talking policy and that that part of
what depresses me a lot about the
political environment this that's the
standard way of talking you talk policy
I'm I'm you know for Medicare I'm
against Medicare I wanna up and I want
to lower it that's fine but what you
have today is a tremendous rebellion
against the distance between the top of
the system at the bottom and any policy
you put in there the massive amount of
distress is going to generate it's gonna
spark another revolt you you do what you
do we're just suggesting you get another
Tea Party probably yeah well but that
let's break that down a little bit
because I think you're right that there
is there's a rejection of the status quo
there's a rejection of the what have
become the structures of power and the
hierarchical difference and inequality
but everything's actually doing it I
think that the movement for something
like Medicare for all they don't see the
government necessarily as the problem I
think they see the government as having
been co-opted by for-profit corporations
and that's what they want to remove it's
not the government that they want to
remove so I don't know that I see the
inconsistency that you're pointing out
there well I mean I I my research with I
mean now dozens of these revolts it's
pretty clear that the government I mean
other data is there here in the US to
government levels of distrust are just
crashing through the floor I mean I
won't say they're a rock bottom they
could still fall a little bit somewhere
between twenty and thirty percent of the
electorate trust their elected
government think about that so what you
are saying though is you you can you
conceiving of some gigantic program that
you will are then gonna be handing off
to this body that you absolutely
distrust I think before we get to the
program we need to recruit reform the
system so that the distance is lowered
and trust and so kinda you can reconcile
the public to our forms of democracy
what would be steps that could be taken
to remove that debt that distance and to
increase trust in the institutions of
power
wouldn't I mean it seems to me that
separating the corporate sort of
hierarchy and influence on government
would be a great first step
yeah I mean that's the problem is in
this fractured environment
nobody's gonna trust you that it's
really happening
mmm the second you stop seeing it out in
front you're gonna start believing that
it's happening behind closed doors so
what you need is a a system that I would
say to be a good beginning would be push
as much decision-making down to us local
level as possible so there are as few
levels between you and the power that is
making decisions as you can get it to be
all right
I mean how many hundreds of levels of
bureaucracy are there between you and
the President of the United States he
might as well live in Mount Olympus with
the gods which is the the Emmanuel
macron ambition right so that has a
change and the one way to start changing
that is to bring down decision-making as
local as possible where people are as
visible as possible and react as
immediately as possible to pressure from
below from the voters the book is
fascinating it's called the revolt of
the public first published in 2014 and
updated in 2018 we've been speaking with
the book's author former CIA analyst
Martin Guri Martin thank you so much I
really do appreciate your time today
yeah I love being here